you
okay it's been a while we have a three
check tournament here this is a
tournament two marathon third tournament
in a row and this time it is three check
oh boy
first player to land a third check is
the winner be very careful okay well
this is a good start I'm winning upon
and is it worthwhile to give up this
Bishop I don't think so let's go here
we're gonna try for this though these
caveman attacks can be pretty good
but that night gonna hurt me that night
might be yeah he's looking for that okay
we don't want this bishop to fall with
check that's for sure
and I think this kind of stuff would
have happened if I took with my queen so
to be very careful if I move my knight
Bishop takes pawn is pretty serious I
think I want to kind of restrict the
bishop there a nice getting to be a
pretty big pain
there's one Czech White has already or
could go forward with
let's try this and jump in here open up
the diagonal these games go so fast let
me tell you okay I feel more comfortable
now that there's only one Bishop around
I want my King here because it's out of
the night check and a bishop whoa whoa
why why didn't I take the Queen huh oh
good
rook up and over when in doubt just do a
rook up and over
ready to do sacrifices yet
Wow that was just a hanging queen
seven seconds
made threat oh I got multiple checks
you
what is this move about ah who's typing
in the chat couldn't he have couldn't he
have just captured the yes the answer to
that is yes you don't have to hit enter
on that one Oh leak out 27 minutes left
okay Michael let's do it
Michael already has two games in
and has not yet
shaved a does it doesn't have an
established rating just yet
okay
well I think it's worthwhile to give up
a pawn here even if this pawn gets
hunted down though it's not entirely
clear how you get that pawn back at
least in a smooth way
right Magnus
smooth okay we're going to go here
and I guess we'll take with the rook I
rely on my night for defense about this
Queen feels a little uncomfortable she
must
we'll go here right now I want to
sacrifice this has to be good
got this stuff right around the corner
check
check here and then
I'm losing track of how many
shucks I have oh yeah I had a check
there okay I can't count
I can't count either not only can I not
calculate I call my god oh boy yeah
yeah and that's the second check if I
get hit with one more check I'm a dead
man can he do it my opponent only needs
one checker Oni
I should have played Bishop rd4
stopping that so we got to stop this
night from doing anything fancy if he
gets here here I cannot stop yeah it's
it's it's scary enough just having one
night close to my king okay well this is
nice I have to worry about the bishop or
the rooks it's just the Knights they
don't kill me anytime soon I'm all right
I think I'm gonna be all right I think
I'm winning now
all right
[Music]
we're going to do similar to the last
game pinpoint this this square
now we got we got something juicy here
is that working I think this is working
check
check here for a second check and I can
rely upon one more piece for ya actually
next the bishops
are good for one more check wherever the
King goes these guys are well happily
give that final check again smokey who
you who just resigned okay we got eight
GT chests Oh for there are 52 in here
okay we number two guy
I'm forgetting how to play like what
what systems to go with
let's try this you have to be really
delicate with the black side for sure
okay
try this try that
like moving this pawn is no good right
now okay we'll do that
and Oh actually this could be pretty
good I'm playing this like it's at three
two that's the that's the
those are the games that I'm used to
when I play three check
three two okay I'm on the night
this should be pretty good actually
the bishop
is this a worthwhile chew okay this is
this is gonna be winning now check and
then that's a second check and this is
third no matter what all right yeah I
think if my opponent played d4 there I
would have been in some hot water
okay 52 in here this is a good crew or a
created tournament still bolo - time to
go
23
okay
first time opponents nice to see
okay well it will stick with the French
I think this is an important
variation to go to go with probably the
most important or the most popular
against well with the three check
variant
now let's put a pond at a dark square
kind of regretting that decision already
[Music]
you
I did this there's queen h5 c5 was a big
lemon
okay try and make something happen
still no checks for
their side and ready to take here let's
see if we could
I look up and over
I want this file to open up
b5 in there rook b8 and b5 I'm gonna do
without castling
oh that is very helpful
peace goes down I'm not going to take
back I just want this file and we're
going to insert us
second check
and I oh hang on there's a third check
okay we got another opponent 216
why am i starting with Knight f3 I do
not know
okay let's put both nights out supposed
to play e4e for is best buy test for
sure in three check
that's what my experience has told me
no reason not to play e4
and now once this night is no longer
enough 6 getting the Queen out to one of
these two is a giant pain for black
and I think I could already sacrifice
here Knight takes check and Knight on
you for following up if Knight takes
here first I have this
check
so this should be too much intakes nine
check 94 and then I have Knight f6 Queen
somewhere so we're going to go
night check queen takes
let's just take like this this should
still be good I should be pretty quick
to get my pieces towards the King ruck
up and over I just don't even want they
don't want that now this is definitely
winning
one takes me to
and King here it's made on the spot with
Queen h5 and King here of the night all
by itself
well not no not really King e7 and my
bishop could play though okay yeah that
went that went wrong having that nice
Center Bishop c5 is is not a good
decision I get that
desirable d4 move in with tempo
make sure the night is there first
though okay yeah as mentioned this is
this is very good for white
which should be for Bishop d2
yeah I really dodged a bullet that
earlier game taking on that F to capture
hmm
let's do this
okay pointing right at the heart
this is excellent now if castles I have
this flushing the night away and then a
sacrifice here
we're just going to sure up the F to
square
even though it doesn't hit with check I
just don't want to expose my King to
these checks maybe six is the safe one
let's try and flush this night away
go in there
he's going to go to b4
I'll Castle after that okay just keep
keep flushing some pieces away
I'll castle 28 seconds
let's try this I want no one before I
also want to secure this point here I
push my queen you have to do that
actually let's jump in here
I want to push because of a capture on
that square
I don't have to move the night just yet
now I do
during your take was check okay this is
this is gone now on takes Maine to
at the Queen here
yeah down on time all right 24 with fire
18 minutes left 24 2016
54 is probably going to stay right
around that point
okay there's a GM as a spectator I just
noticed hop in there man even if it's a
even if it's a late join
just just hanging out just observing
okay these fiend keto systems are
definitely not the most testing
but it makes it III find that these
games are actually pretty pretty
interesting you know it's a it's a it's
a nice little build up
and then uh you know you end up getting
like a nice combination at some stage a
nice flurry of sacra flow of sacrifices
so that night needs to find a new home
let's put them in a pin yeah it's like
neither of us are even
yeah we're not very close to getting at
one another as king now this is pretty
weakening so I could I could start
thinking about this stuff and point some
pieces there you know it's because even
as a Sakura for this is a threat now
yeah that was that was a trap
try for maybe that or even this
how about we take here and then go here
where's the Queen go
I think this is actually working that's
a pretty slick move rook takes rook I
think I'm just going to recapture
you know should still be better
you know this is fancy I think I have
this move
okay maybe not now that the knight is
defending h2 twenty seconds till the ten
seconds for my opponent now I think this
is working
now we take care first
oh yeah and then I just run a piece I
didn't have to go in for fancy tactics
wanted to make something happen with
that let's just tuck my king away
form on the bishop
I had this check
okay not the smoothest finish oh did he
is in there
he wasn't just watching he's in there
very strong player a GM is in the mix
very nice to see and we're not even at
the halfway point just yet
ok number 2 guy who was right on my
heels here a very important game new
account just new to the variant a new
account he's out has a loss in there
let's try for c5
I forget what I was supposed to do here
yeah
you know you're gonna you're gonna drop
in there pretty sure it's just a matter
of when
okay
I think take like this and then go here
how the computer do this to me
and it made me struggle there's actually
a pretty serious threat in mind this and
if the night captures my night there's a
check here I don't know if it's it's
best to do that really in the in the
tank here
tell you what we're going to insert this
check the naked block
going to move
14 seconds
they're playing slow
[Music]
going to start
flying
at some point and kick it into a higher
gear
I have one check against me
am i okay with that
they're kicking it into a higher gear
why do I allow that second check
and they have a second
another check
check and then I got made next that
Queen almost killed me there as only
their second loss okay I have thirty two
twenty four twenty twenty
fire hasn't slipped up how many three
check games has not not enough to have
an established rating I am on fire next
opponent oke for 13 minutes to go French
defence and nearly played d4 and that's
just a losing move
on the spot losing move
forced a forced win for black one wrong
slip
okay we push
and I'm just gonna castle I don't I
don't want to even allow a check so
let's just safeguard f2 and B be happy
that this Bishop were and this night
won't hurt me anytime soon and I keep
the bishop there and we'll take with the
night because I want to free my queen
as I mentioned once there's not a knight
on f6 these squares are just so juicy
for the Queen I don't want to take care
cuz it'll be quick castle and then that
could really backfire though now where's
their King gonna go maybe now I will
caps capture on g7 Brooks can't be
connected and we'll play it simple I'm
up upon they're never going to get at my
king
think so at least my knight has a really
good square it's the other thing let's
go here I don't want this bishop to have
a nice diagonal and I am definitely
getting out there King might my king is
gonna be super cozy and their king is
going to feel some some heat right now
the Kingo yeah that's that's a problem
it's a second check
taken the could've captured the rook but
I think the knight does it all by
himself King here here I have a check
good job Knight
the MVP of that one okay thirty six
twenty seven twenty fours these guys
still have fire okay he Pharma getting
more whites than blacks in this one
oh this is already a loss
definitely with that even if the pawn
even if there's a pawn advance I'm
taking that on
I just need one more check
Night Moves I take here
I don't have to I don't have to rush it
there may have been something okay
I have that if the Knight takes Knight
takes Knight the King has to move you
have to go to h8 okay that's me maybe
lost track forgot that I could take was
check okay ten minutes 29 seconds I
think he just finished it's not in a
game oh we're not getting a pairing okay
this guy again um I think I'm gonna try
something different I don't like that
c5 move maybe something happened with
their computer that when we played it
seemed like they went into a too big of
a think it maybe something was off with
the computer now they're going into
another thing kind of early
that no
you
okay here and f5 is my idea I think I
want to eliminate this Knight this
Bishop could be staring off into space
if I don't Wow now isn't that fancy
okay we're gonna we're gonna go here I
guess
Wow is that fancy
okay oh maybe I get the F file to play
with
the bishop isn't going to contribute
here
that was a pretty slick move that threat
here was just a bit too serious okay now
we go here
shop here and we try and
get at the king
so how about this and then my piece is
kind of a spring to life feel like I
should have mate soon here and then a
discovered check have one check I'm
going to go in for this with the night
jumping in here
11 seconds Knight f3 you have to do that
all right
hmm
I want g5
g5 is where I want to be
yeah
and they start to fly oh I realize that
that was
you
oh my god they had me oh they just pick
your favorite Megan - they were down on
time what is with that that's a really I
don't know how to describe that opponent
I don't know they go slow in the
beginning and then they kick it into
some higher gear that is I don't know it
feels much stronger all of a sudden
tough player
hey ninety-four I believe is best
you kind of have to just go ahead and
take in that position it's one of the
interesting things with the three check
variant once there's that tension
between the Queen Knight and the King
Knight whether you're here or castled
the capture and f3 is is with check so
you have to initiate the the capture
let's go here
I want to see capture on the square okay
want to ignore
this tension I want to go after the king
so queen h5
okay now this squared is looking really
nice
alrighty or we're doing something here
soon okay I think I'm close to
calculating some mate quite I have two
checks I just need one more piece around
know what am I talking about I could
just make by regular means yeah I'm
mating on g7 if they take on f6 I'm
trying to calculate a third a third
check at their check what wouldn't be
needed checkmate in its just in the
second check
alright 48 36 36 6 minutes to go so I'm
a cushion these guy were the top three
are flawless here this is my third black
against this opponent
can I get I get a game with light um all
right we're gonna we're gonna try for
this set up again
all right right right right
I forgot about the
okay I think I think Queen f6 is a move
here
you
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna try and uh
not get killed there's one check please
don't get a third check Bishop there
Queen f6
this night is gonna mmm he's gonna hurt
me maybe 96
I can check here they want and I have to
take with the pawn taking with the Queen
I'm gone they have one check King here
see they're going into the tank again
extreme tactics they listening Oh
where's the force mate clean here to
here okay I can't get hit with one more
checker I'm dead oh please no
okay let's control the night on h-file
feel it open I have a check here
at one check
threatening me
yes
Wow okay that was scary whenever my your
opponent only needs one check okay four
minutes left is he seeing a game he's
not in a game I think we're finally
gonna get paired up
give me white please there's a serious
advantage with white
for sure okay okay maybe maybe we
you do something good here
alright let's push let's see how much
how much Theory is known here
see how much I can recall
I think this is a win for me with this
move
I can't I can't figure
I don't recall the exact line so I just
wasted a boatload of time there
huh
okay
hmm I want to get rid of that light
square bishop
you
yeah wait I have this and then I could
get a second check
start taking the bishop
Wow
here
be careful this diagonal
rook takes pawn here I think I could
allow I think I could allow this check
I'm two checks away take here take here
clean block block check they can only
get to 12 seconds
think I have it
the rook hi could I have three pieces
and I only need two checks I have more
time
let's see
offering a queen exchange
check and I got it I got it I got it I
got it okay they're down on time I'm
getting the next check who okay
56 44 44 two minutes left
well that was tough Oh hmm I think they
just must have just missed the night a
seven move
initially I was just going to take the
bishop with check but Knight takes I
think was even better
I know
close very close okay 126 this is
probably going to be the last game
Connect nights still allowing this night
move I keep forgetting about the night
move
no-no-no I could go in for this I mean
it worked last time it was scary but it
worked last time I just have to hope one
other piece can't get at me
yeah there isn't a bishop here okay so
we're in this is similar setup that I go
with I have to take like that and I have
to avoid a third check now but the queen
is still on the board so in the other
game my opponent took my queen
you
Oh
well
works I can't stop Queen takes here next
there is that this isn't working though
oh there's Queen takes pawn here - no
there was no saving okay I'm just I'm
all they had mate I weren't they pulling
the trigger on that yeah that works as
well
Queen takes you give them the win it's
their man hit me there it is
okay down in the last game had enough of
a cushion though
56:48 46 already 61 and all who else was
in there
yeah that was definitely the better
approach my opponent did in that one
keeping inserting the check with the
bishop and then keeping the Queens on
the board she's a tough piece too to
negate for sure she's pretty much always
guaranteed if she's even half active she
will be able to land some
some check all right to the sixty of you
good games all that was fun as usual GM
saying I got to study some theory yeah I
have to I have to do some refreshers as
well it's been a while
you